so
darren i believe we're all set
okay is she going to be present this
morning um
i believe she says she's there and so i
think we're all set thank you okay all
right let's go ahead and call the case
thank you
recording in progress
your honor
colleen the people of the state of
michigan versus ethan crumley 2022 279
506 fc
good morning council appearances for the
record when you give your appearance
please indicate whether or not you can
send to proceed via the zone this
morning
good morning your honor assistant
prosecutor kelly collins appearing on
behalf of the people and we do consent
to zoom
good morning your honor martial
washington appearing on behalf of the
people and again we do consent to this
matter being held on soon
good morning runner paulette michelle
lofton on behalf of mr crumbly we also
consent to proceed by zoom this morning
good morning you're honoring me half on
behalf of david conway i consent to zoo
this morning
good morning around our deborah h
mckelvey court appointed lawyer guardian
ad litem for ethan crumley and i have no
objections to proceeding with this
matter on zoom this morning
thank you good morning to all council
morning mr crumbly today's date and time
separate review hearing mr crumbly are
you okay with proceeding via zoom this
morning you have an absolute right to be
in person in court today and i just want
to know are you okay with proceeding via
zoom
okay thank you as the court previously
stated today's vegan time set for a
review hearing under the juvenile
justice and delinquency prevention act
we are to have a review hearing every 30
days regarding the defendant's placement
whether or not he should be placed at
the continue to be placed at the oakland
county jail or whether or not he should
be transferred to the children's village
we did have a hearing on february 22nd
2022 the court took the matter under
advisement and issued a written opinion
in order on march 1st 2022
continuing continuing the defendant's
placement at the oakland county jail and
today is the review hearing the court is
in receipt of the people's memorandum of
law following the hearing um is there
any additional information from the
people that you would like to place on
the record
no your honor i believe that the
follow-up supplemental brief does speak
for itself
that would be all that we have
thank you miss collins in defense are
you a receipt of the people's memorandum
of law following the hearing
yes i received it last evening okay is
there anything that you would like to
add for today's purposes
your honor there has not been many
changes since the last hearing i know
there's an update on the education
portion and i believe miss mikel will be
speaking to that
thank you go ahead ms mckelvey
uh well your honor i just need to
address one issue in the memorandum from
the uh prosecutor's offices i received
last evening
i think it's important for
the court to recognize their memorandum
still says that it's the parents
responsibility to provide education
and the section of the statute that
they're using
says and i i'm concerned that they just
go over you know ignore it is that it
says
uh the child's parent guardian or other
person in this state having control in
charge of the child which right now and
as of the date of the incident has been
the oakland county jail and i just think
it's important to keep that in
perspective because even at our last
hearing
there was testimony that everybody
believed that it's the parents
responsibility and it's no longer the
parents responsibility
but with that being said
um
on tuesday evening i received an
extensive email
from
marianne george from she's a senior
assistant at a corporation council
and
it involved
what
educational plans
that are available that will either give
him a high school equivalency diploma
or a ged
and the two pads uh that exist
and i did meet with mr crumley at the
jail yesterday afternoon to discuss all
this and it's an issue that we do have
approximately a month
uh to deal with as uh the earliest
implementation of anything cannot occur
until he is 16 and he will be 16 at the
end of april
uh there are are two options she
provided me a list that they are
investigating
of what they call either strict
disciplinary academies or cyber schools
unfortunately
he cannot
proceed with that
which would be a basically a regular
school day
until the 20
2022-2023 school year because the
as i know i'm sure the court's aware um
and everybody um
that twice a year every school district
does you know head count and funding is
based upon that head count and we are
past obviously the
uh second semester head count
so for funding purposes he will not be
able to start any
a full
school
cyber school year until next september
or this coming september the other
option um
would involve uh
through the department the michigan
department of labor and economic
opportunity he would be able at 16 we
would execute paperwork uh and as his
lawyer guardian advice i can
sign it as the court representative to
implement uh either the high school
equivalency program
or um a ged
and additionally that would once he has
achieved either the high school
equivalency diploma or the ged he then
would be able to continue in that
program
to be able to um do some community
college courses um miss george indicated
that she has uh talked with captain vita
about being able to provide him uh his
own laptop to be able to have
you know a certain block of time um
every day for him to be able to uh work
on that uh program and the khan academy
app that is currently on the um
tablet he can use to supplement if there
are certain areas that he needs to
work on once he takes the practice test
and um and then she is also working on
how to be able to have the
um
actual test that he would have to take
to be monitored um so
there has been a lot of movement in that
and i appreciate all her efforts um
and as i said i did speak with him
yesterday he is thinking about what path
he wants to uh proceed with but the
earliest that we can start implementing
that would uh have to be after his 16th
birthday which is in approximately
another month thank you for that
information mr kelby uh miss collins or
miss washington in the response to that
no your honor i'm glad that they're
making progress with regard to the
options that uh the defendant has
available to him
thank you very much and it's so noted by
the court uh is there any additional
information that any attorney wanted to
present before the court makes its
ruling regarding the defendant's
continued placement
all right i think nothing from the
people your honor no your honor thank
you
thank you to all the attorneys the court
has been presented with a memorandum of
law from the prosecutor's office uh in
summary the prosecutor's office has been
trying to work
uh with defense counsel as outlined by
ms mckelvey
to try to get an educational program for
the defendant to comply with the
michigan statutes that he is to continue
with
education because he is indeed a minor
and it does appear to the court that
that has been
ongoing and continue to
uh becoming a non-issue now because it's
in this court's opinion at least i
believe that the parties are working
together
to resolve that issue however the court
has not been presented with any
additional information or new
information that caused this port to
disturb its march 1
2022 opinion order therefore the court
will continue the defendant's placement
at the oakland county jail and we will
set this matter for an additional review
hearing slash free trial we'll treat the
next one as a pre-trial as well in the
next 30 days pursuant to the juvenile
justice and delinquency prevention act
that next date will be
thursday april 21st
2022 at 9 00 a.m
does that work for all council
yes your honor
in person or by zoom
it because it will be another hearing
quite similar to this one um the court
is okay with doing it via zoom unless
any attorney has an objection
not at this time right now no question
from the people you're on
okay thank you i will see you all april
21st 2022 at 9 00 am via zoom before you
all log off my last question actually
two comments uh one the court still has
the binder from the evidentiary hearing
has been kept under locking key in my
office but pursuant to the court rule
the court would like to return uh this
evidence so if the prosecutor's office
could send a runner over
to pick up the binder it will be
available this morning
so i can return this evidence back to
the prosecutor's office
as well as i wanted to
inquire has anyone heard anything from
the forensic center
yes your honor examination has taken
place um we are just waiting on the
report i expect it probably will be
another 45 days okay we will discuss
this issue again at the next review
hearing slash pre-trial on april 21st
2022 at 9am via zoom is there anything
else from either party
your honor does the court intend to
issue its own written order as a result
of today's review or should i should the
parties provide something to the court
uh please prepare an order but for this
one according to the act it says that
it shall be made in writing but it
wasn't clear whether or not each
30-day review needed a writing so let's
go ahead and have a writing just to be
on the safe side so the parties could go
ahead and submit an order with all the
attorney signatures i would greatly
appreciate it we will do that
thank you very much anything else
no you're honest from the people you're
honored
right thank you everyone you all have a
great morning and a great day
thank you as well
recording stopped
you